the societies as we struggle to meet the
challenges ahead
as the pandemic stretches on and its
consequences accumulate
palestinians and israelis alike are
feeling the effects
i remain particularly concerned about
the spread of the virus in gaza
and long-term damage to the palestinian
economy and social cohesion
including the effects on education for
the next generation
last month at the un general assembly
the secretary general renewed his appeal
for abnormal ceasefire in response to
covert 19
calling for a major push to make this
happen by the end of the year
in this con in the context of the
israeli-palestinian conflict
this means focusing on preventive
diplomacy to avoid escalation and war in
gaza
working with all to alleviate the health
and social economic
consequences modernizing the economic
relationship between both sides
and working towards re-establishing
credible negotiations
with the goal of two-state solution in
line with relevant u.n resolutions
the commitment of the international
community to support both sides in this
process
remains unwavering what is required
however is leadership from both israelis
and palestinians to work together
and advance the course of peace mr
president
during the reporting period the
resurgence of kobe 19 has seriously
compounded the humanitarian and economic
challenges on the ground
with the significant tightening of
restrictions in israel
and gaza and an extension of the state
of emergency throughout the occupied
palestinian territory
for 30 days from october 2nd the
humanitarian community has continued its
efforts to address the pandemic
including by addressing critical gaps in
medical supplies and equipment
responding to a severe shortage of
equipment including corporate 19 testing
kits
across the opt un agencies ngos and
international organizations have
delivered materials for more than
100 000 tests dozens of ventilators and
oxygen therapy machines
these new supplies along with millions
of personal protective equipment items
are crucial to athletes to contain the
spread of the virus
arrangements brokered by the u.n
continue to allow the transfer of
patients from gaza
for medical treatment outside the strip
and for important humanitarian supplies
into the occupied palestinian
territories
even as the pa's decision to hold
coordination with israel remains in
place
i wish to reiterate however that the u.n
cannot replace the roles and
responsibilities of the palestinian
authority
or the government of israel any
increased responsibilities for the ui
in this regard should be limited and
time-bound
i welcome the ongoing support from the
dollar community to the uncovered 19
response service
urge increased assistance as this crisis
extends into the foreseeable future
mr president as we remain focused on
urgent health concerns
the viability of the palestinian
authority
is being severely undermined by an
economic and fiscal crisis that has been
exacerbated
by the palestinian decision to end
civilian and security coordination with
israel
the fiscal crisis derives primarily from
a collapse in domestic tax revenues
during the government emergency and from
the government's refusal to receive its
clearance revenues
the united nations stands ready to
mediate solutions to the fiscal crisis
and to get the palestinian economy
on better footing i reiterate the
secretary general's call for both sides
to re-examine the nature of their
economic relationship
and improve it for the benefit of both
peoples
in this context i appeal to the
palestinian leadership
to resume its coordination with israel
and accept its clearance revenues
money that belongs to the palestinian
people and cannot be replaced by donor
funding
when public health conditions permit
israel should facilitate free
movement of palestinian workers and
goods into israel
and between the occupied west bank and
the gaza strip
for its part the international community
should accelerate humanitarian and
development initiatives in the opt
including those outlined in the
humanitarian response plan
and the uncovered 19 responses
mr president on the 14th to 15th of
october israeli authorities
advanced some 5 000 settlement housing
units
this resumption of major settlement
activity which follows an eight-month
break
in area c housing advancements is of
great concern
the move by the high planning committee
is one of the largest collective
advancements to date
approximately 85 of these units
are in settlements and outlying
locations deep inside the west bank
all in areas impeding the contiguity of
a future palestinian state
while the location of these units is
particularly worried i reiterate that
all settlements are illegal in the
international law
and remain a substantial obstacle to
peace settlement related activities
should cease
as they undermine the prospect of
achieving a viable two-state solution
in line with u.n resolutions
international law
and prior agreements during the
reporting period
israeli authorities also demolished or
seized 59 palestinian-known structures
in area c
and three in east jerusalem displacing
82 palestinians
including 23 women and 40 children
affecting 200 others
demolitions were performed due to the
lack of israeli-issued building permits
which are nearly impossible for
palestinians to obtain
a donor-funded school in the pedaling
community of rasaltin
and the ramallah government faces an
evident threat of demolition
due to the lack of a birth building boat
if demolished
it would affect nearly 50 children an
israeli court has issued an interim
injunction halting the demolition
pending further legal proceedings
there have been no demolitions of
residential structures in east jerusalem
in the reporting period i urge israel to
cease demolitions and seizures of
palestinian property throughout the
occupied west bank
including east jerusalem in line with
its obligations under international
humanitarian law
and to allow palestinians to develop
their communities
mr president over the past months israel
has not responded to visa renewal
requests for international staff members
from the u.n human rights office
while the office continues to deliver on
its mandate most international ohchhr
staff members
are now working from outside the mission
area
after the release of the report to the
human rights council
on business activities and israeli
settlements in february 2020
israel has frozen its relations with the
oschr
i'm deeply concerned that critically
mandated work on human rights by the
united nations is obstructed in this
manner
i urge israel to facilitate the return
of international staff members
to the opt mr president
on the 24th september
fatah announced it had reached a series
of understandings with hamas
including on agreement to hold
legislative and presidential elections
under a proportional representation
system
these discussions are welcome
development and represent yet another
effort
at organizing long-overdue and
much-needed palestinian leadership
elections
on the basis of the pll platform
palestinian people have not been allowed
to elect their leaders for too long
democracy and elections are critical to
enabling people to determine the
direction of their national force
the u.n stands ready to support the
palestinian people
in exercising their democratic rights
mr president violent incidents
unfortunately continued throughout the
reporting period
on october the 1st israeli defense
forces arrested two palestinian men
who had crossed into israel through the
gaza security threats carrying a
homemade bomb
the next day the idea opened fire
towards a group of palestinians who
approached the security defense in gaza
injuring one of them on the 5th of
october militants fired
one rocket from gaza towards israel the
rocket landed in an open area in israel
with no injuries or damages reported
in response israeli air force aircraft
fired two missiles targeting a military
observation post in gaza
no injuries were reported as well on the
20th of october the idea
announced that it had located and
exposed a hamas tunnel
entering israeli territory from the
southern gaza strip
a few hours after the discovery
palestinian militants fired one rocket
from gaza towards israel
the rocket was intercepted by the ibs
iron dome air defense system
and no injuries or damages were reported
in response
israeli air force responded by strike
king
an underground structure in an
agricultural field in gaza
no injuries were reported in total five
rockets were fired
and other
um
is
foreign
my
thank you for presiding over this
meeting and for the leadership role of
russia
and the pursuit of middle east let me
also thank
my brother muhammad ali for
participating in this meeting
and to welcome his excellency
it's time to drop all talking points
to claim that the palestinians never
missed an opportunity to miss an
opportunity
when in fact signed an agreement with
israel
after the start of the first ever
negotiations between the two sides
despite all the shortcomings
which history has proven history
it is to consider that israel's rights
to security could justify
its probation and oppression of an
entire nation for decades
or justify denying us our right to
self-determination
to a sovereign and independent state and
or justifying
when our positions are actually aligned
with the international questions and the
resolutions of this council
while israeli positions and policies
flagrantly in breach
the parties identified final status
issues
that should be negotiated based on
internationally agreed terms of
reference
and parameters by 1999
shall remain
of the jordan valley and with it most of
our natural resources
these positions are contemptuous and
unlawful
and they translate into issues
israel does not want to enter its
this call must be accompanied by
measures
to incentivize respect for obligations
and to disawait from illegal unilateral
actions it is no longer enough to say
settlements are illegal
we could have tried to find answers to
israel's
violence
while making such a choice while on the
other hand israel is rewarded
what is being encouraged
is
[Music]
mandated by this body to advance peace
and the security council
preparations to convene an international
conference
with the participation of all concerned
parties early next year
to engage
is the ultimate demonstration of our
commitment to peace
including through meetings of this
council
such as this one
israel decided only under the pressure
to freeze its plans to formal annexation
in other
we will
as long as israel does not bear the cost
of occupation
and instead continues its benefits
it will never negotiate
the international
by helping them reach an agreement and
implementing it
and by enforcing a binding time frame
the international peace conference can
generate the necessary
momentum and mobilize the international
community at large
hundreds of thousands were displaced
fragmentation
history has taught them
the palestinian people's resilience have
all been
sorely tested and yet
there is an independent state missing
you cannot solve the middle east
equation
and our freedom will never be compatible
with israeli soldiers
in our streets
yesterday by israeli soldiers who had
apprehended him
and kept hitting him on his neck
with the butt of their rifles until he
could no longer breathe
ask the mother of the children
the owner of a house built by years
we want
thank you mr president
is
can israel unmute the mic and camera
please
is
yes ambassador we can hear you we cannot
see the video but would suggest you read
your statements
if the camera's not working because we
can hear your audience thank you
mr president it is an honor to speak
before the security council for the
first time since assuming my role as the
permanent representative of the state of
israel
i have served on israel's security
cabinet and in several ministerial
positions
dealing with issues such as
counter-terrorism and the ongoing
attempts to delegitimize my god
i believe that the un as a whole and the
security council in particular
can be a force for good in the world but
especially today
when the world is facing extenuating
health and economic challenges
in my view the council should serve as a
model
for how nations can set aside their
differences
and unite to tackle international
problems and promote peace and security
in the two months since i arrived in new
york i have witnessed
a sharing disannounce between
what this council chooses to focus on
and what is actually happening in the
middle east
during this short period i witnessed the
council ignoring opportunities
to promote peace while simultaneously
choosing
not to act in the face of grave threats
i was told by many that the council
holds an
institutional bias against israel
despite
these criticisms i want to keep an open
mind
i want to prove wrong all
in order to better understand the
council's priorities
in the middle east
the situation in the middle east
including the palestinian question
one would expect the council to focus on
the most
important issues facing the middle east
routinely overlook critical issues and
focus
only on the palestinians
the momentum of peace between four
countries
in a turbulent region as the u.n body
entrusted with developing friendly
relations among nations
surely the council should discuss the
abram accords
and the most recent peace agreement
between israel and sudan
absolutely and yet the only debate this
council held on the historic
peace agreement between israel and the
uae and bahrain
was an informal one to understand how
significant
this agreement are agreements are
consider that it was in khartoum
in 1967 that the arab league adopted the
khartoum resolution
and the infamous three notes no peace
with israel
no recognition of israel and no
negotiations
for our children
growing acceptance
on this unprecedented paradigm shift and
how we can build on this
agreement perhaps we could discuss today
how the abraham accords and the new
israeli sudanese alliance
presents new opportunities for dialogue
and prosperity
how these agreements will enhance
cooperation in the fields of security
sustainability technology innovation
health and more these accords
are an important milestone that will
serve to advance
further agreements with other arab and
muslim countries
they disprove
maybe that is exactly why the
palestinian leadership
opposes them instead of viewing the
accords
there's a new opportunity to kick-start
negotiations
the palestinians have attacked the
emirates bahrainians and sudanese
calling their decisions to have
relations with israel
are betrayed
now everyone can see that the
palestinians incite against
any country that seeks peace in the
region
even its fellow arab league members the
fact that the palestinians attacked
those who make peace with israel
demonstrates
it isn't surprising that the palestinian
refusal to see the agreement
as an opportunity president abbas
has refused every peace offering made by
the state of israel
actually to be more precise he has
refused
every offer that he has bothered
responding to
former prime minister is still waiting
for a response
to the generous offer he made in 2008.
the palestinian representative here
calls for a peace
conference don't be fooled by this it is
only
another distraction a conference will
not bring peace
the only way to achieve real peace is
through direct bilateral negotiations
prime minister netanyahu has invited
president abbas to jerusalem many times
he has even offered to go to ramallah
but abbas
wastes time calling for another
useless conference instead this council
should call on the palestinians to begin
negotiations
based on the american vision for peace
which is a good starting point
for realistic sustainable peace
mr president in a debate titled the
situation in the middle east including
the palestinian question
shouldn't this new era of peace which
has a huge impact on the region
in addition to discussing opportunities
for peace the council must also discuss
the destabilizing force in the region
namely
iran iran it's surprising
but i actually want to thank iran i want
to
thank the regime for the role it has
played in bringing the moderate forces
in the region
closer together ironically iran's
extreme
and murderers ways have contributed to
the historic agreement
nevertheless iran and its terrorist
proxies remain the biggest
threat to peace and security in the
region
of using violence to create a shia
hegemony
in the region it should top the agenda
in all debates
in the middle east iran's continued
aggression
threatens to take many more innocent
lives muslims
jews christians opposing iran's nuclear
nuclear ambitions while allowing it to
buy and sell
other lethal weapons puts the entire
region
in great danger the fact that almost
all members of this council were willing
to let the arms embargo expired goes
into question
this body's commitment to international
peace and security
the sanctions on iran which were
re-initiated by the u.s
triggered snapback remains in full
effect
iran is also one of the biggest human
rights
violators in the world one example
is it's obsessive
iran has executed over 4 300 people
4 300 people including miners
women members of the lgbt community
journalists and anti-government
protesters
should this not be discussed in a debate
on the situation in the middle east
in a maximum pressure campaign against
iran
it must prevent the regime in tehran
from continuing to develop its nuclear
capabilities
obtaining advanced weapons and violating
human rights
for israel and other arab countries
this is an existence one day
mr president many more countries will
realize
it threatens them too let's hope
when discussing security in the middle
east there is another iran-related
threat
that is barely discussed by the council
it has been nearly a month since prime
minister netanyahu revealed
new intelligence about a hizballah arms
depot
embedded in bahrain in beirut's
neighborhood or the terrible explosion
last august the city's board killed 200
people
and injured thousands this has not
stopped hezbollah
from putting lebanese lives at risk of
another
similar disaster this is not the first
time that hezbollah has used lebanese
civilians
and of un security council resolutions
1680 and 1701
if the council truly cares about the
future of the middle east
how is it possible that not all council
members
have designated hezbollah in its
entirety
as a terrorist organization should
the israeli-palestinian conflict is also
of course an important issue and should
be a part of the debate
yet while discussing it every month for
the last 20 years
key elements have been neglected if you
are looking for the real obstacle to
peace
look at the palestinians long record of
incitement and hate
pa textbooks incite to violence
and promote terrorism and anti-semitism
through its pay to slay program the pa
rewards
terror against israeli civilians
maybe part of the answer to the
palestinian question
can be found here the pa spends
hundreds of millions of dollars a year
on its pay to slay program
just think how that money could have
been spent this year
fighting kovid 19. the u.n regularly
produces one-sided distorted reports
about
alleged israeli violations of
palestinian palestinian rights
perhaps a discussion should be held
about the palestinian authorities
violation of its own people's right
including the basic right to choose
their own leaders
israel as you know has held more
elections in a year
than the pa has held in the last 15.
for decades many in the international
community have fixated on a single
solution to the conflict
they vote for the same anti-israel
resolutions recycle all talking points
and ignore
issues that are crucial for ending the
conflict
they also ignore the fact that this
approach has only
emboldened palestinian rejectionism
perhaps the council members are too
accustomed
to the ritual of these debates to see
that they have been
completely ineffective in answering the
palestinian
question we all know what einstein said
about trying the same thing over and
over and expecting
different results mr president
while the council's talking points have
not changed for decades
the middle east has three historic
agreements considered
impossible to achieve were reached in
just two months
this council should embrace the accords
and use them as a catalyst to promote
peace and security in the region
it can facilitate the next round of
agreements
i am committed to proving wrong all
those who say that the security council
is a lost cause however ignoring the
most
pressing issues in the middle east and
expressing bias when discussing the
israeli-palestinian conflict
makes it hard to do the council must
recommit itself to pursuing peace and
security
and not let politics dictate its actions
in the middle east
i remain optimistic that the council can
fulfill
its mandate and i look forward to
working
with you all in that in november
is
foreign
please
[Music]
thank you mr president i would like to
thank you
for convening this meeting
mr
deeply president over the overall
situation
in the gaza another occupying
palestinian territories
and most importantly humanitarian
conditions in this
area
53 of the population is living in
poverty
following the collapse of all production
sectors
business social services and
infrastructure
movement prescription stemming from
coveted
further increase
when
medical resources and business
facilities
and who live
we call on the international community
to direct their support
his own form and through all tenants
perhaps the palestinian people who have
come this month
crisis support needs to be affected
while coordinating and people with
priority given to the delivery of
humanitarian
assistance
it's important to help them
hostilities
[Music]
palestinian
international law
[Music]
1967 lies
foreign
[Music]
thank you mr president thank you deputy
foreign
19. once again
officials
a
will spur economy
is
and considerations
deals
against
is
fellow council members
that
[Music]
is
state
and their desire for peace
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
a
foreign
thank you mr president
i also thank the special coordinator
and we welcome the participation of the
honorable foreign minister of the state
of palestine
and our
which recognizes the legitimate
aspirations and security needs of both
palestinians and israel
israel and palestine israel must make
sincere efforts not to undermine
the peace process and to build the
military for the progress
negotiations this year
marks 53 years of the israeli occupation
of palestine
territory and this time the
international community must refrain
sorry must reaffirm our collective
support for a two-state
solution on the basis of the 1967
borders and spain
to achieve a violence
solution to the conflict
the time has come mr president for the
international community to meet our
collective responsibility
to bring an end to the occupation of the
palestinian state
on october 14th and 15th
the israeli government approved their
plan to build
5 000 settlement units in the west bank
these settlements as well as the
acquisition of palestinian territory by
forces
long-standing international consensus on
the relevant u.n
immediately
was resolution sorry and forgive me to
um 242
338 and as a reaffirmed in subsequent
resolutions we also call on member
states to increase funding
as it continues to provide assistance
and protection
for millions of palestinian refugees
in conclusion we sincerely hope that a
two-state solution
with
and last
[Music]
is
thank you mr president and my thanks
also to special
coordinator for his briefing today
as foreign
a shift which must now proceed in
parallel with steps to resolve
the israeli palestinians there is much
to be done to rebuild trust
the suspension of the threat of
annexation was the first step
it must now
settlement units in the west bank
the expansion of settlements violates
international law
and is a counterproductive step in light
of the positive developments i've spoken
of
between israel
by the possible demolition by israeli
authorities
of a palestinian school funded by the
international community
the right to education and it is
essential to have a strong and
thriving palestinian education system in
order to provide opportunities for the
next generation
to hold such actions
the united kingdom has expressed our
concern of the increase in the subtle
environment
the destruction of olive trees and the
stealing of produce
coinciding with the palestinian olive
harvest
as the occupying power the israeli
security forces must provide appropriate
protections
israeli defense forces uh discovery on
20th october
of a tunnel penetrating dozens of yards
into israeli territory
there have also been further rocket
launches this month
and a return to launching ied balloons
uk condemns such indiscriminate attacks
against israeli civilians
we continue to call upon hamas and other
terrorists
to permanently end their incitement and
rocket fire
against israel these negative actions
must stop we
[Music]
forward progress on efforts towards a
peaceful resolution
of the israeli palestinian we continue
to support
a two-state solution based on 1967
lines with jerusalem as a shed
ultimately there is no substitute for
direct talks between the palestinians
which is the only way to
is
mr president thank you and let me start
by
highlighting that germany welcomes the
normalization between israel on the one
side and
the united arab emirates bahrain and
sudan
these developments are an important step
towards
more stability and peaceful relations
between israel and the arab
arabic world as the israeli
ambassador said earlier these
developments offering new opportunities
for further agreements and from our
perspective they also provide a unique
momentum to stimulate the
resumption of cooperation and peace
talks between
israel and palestine we remain convinced
that sustainable peace security and
stability in the middle east can
only be reached with a just lasting and
comprehensive solution to the
israeli-palestinian conflict
on the basis of international law
relevant to land resolution
and internationally agreed parameters
to pick up an argument used before only
because international law
security council resolutions have become
of age
doesn't mean that they are less
important or
less relevant
this conflict can and must finally be
resolved not just thought to be managed
without this we will only see a
continuation of energy
violence and bloodshed evidenced by the
recent missile attacks from gaza against
israel
let me reiterate germany's condemnation
of all attacks and threats against
israel by hamas
and other terrorist groups including the
repeated firing of prophets from gaza
israel has the right to defend itself
against such acts
authority has not criticized what is
happening there and has not
mentioned this and it's not nothing said
about hate speech
against
we are deeply concerned by the most
recent decision taken by the israeli
authorities
on the construction of more than 4 900
settlement building units
israeli settlements activities in the
occupied palestinian territories
are that remain illegal under
international laws
severely undermine the prospects for
ending the occupation and for a viable
and continuous palestinian state within
the framework of the negotiating to
state solutions
that the israeli permanent
representative has not mentioned
anything about this incredible illegal
as we have emphasized directly with the
government of israel
this step also undermines efforts to
rebuild trust between israelis and
palestinians
with a view to resuming dialogue
to immediately halt all settlement
constructions including in east
jerusalem
and sensitive areas such as haram
as well as confiscations evictions and
demolitions of palestinian structures
in east jerusalem and the west bank
israel trust that israeli annexation
plans are truly and permanently
suspended and call upon israel to end
the expansion of settlements that will
not recognize any changes to the fourth
june
situation in israel where elections take
place every few months as a
model i
we hope that such elections will
center in jerusalem for treating the
secretary general of the palestinian
liberation
organization due to a life-threatening
covet 19 in fact
speedy and fully recovered and we are
grateful to hadassah for living up to
its declared mission and i quote
to extend a hand to all without
regard for race religion or ethnic
origin
but this is the spirit that is so sorely
needed
foreign
a
is
yes
[Music]
is
foreign
[Music]
is
activity
foreign
palestinians
thank you thank you very much mr
president
first of all i would like to warmly or
welcome the
deputy foreign minister of russia the
deputy minister for foreign fest of
vietnam as well as secretary
of state for foreign affairs of tunisia
and of course
his excellency riyad maliki foreign
minister of palestine
to this very important meeting i would
also like to express my appreciation
to the special coordinator nikolai
bladenov for his briefing
on the current situation in the occupied
palestine territory
we continue to hear grim and grima
report from the ground
and i think like others also this
continues to be reported
by nikolaj on this very important issue
excellency it is regrettable that
another act of bad faith has been
committed by israel
as we have learned recently on the 14th
and 15th of october 2020
the israeli authorities approved the
construction
of yet another 5 000 settlement units
in the occupied palestinian territory
development is neither surprising
the creeping annexation is testament
that israel's
administration plan is alive and well
collective efforts to realize a
two-state solution
based on the pre-1967 borders
cannot be realized when international
laws and relevant
u.n resolutions are violated
and ignored repeatedly by israel
indonesia condemns this latest violation
of international law and once again
demands israel to immediately cease all
of its illegal settlement activities
in the occupied
and an end to impunity the expansion
of the illegal settlement clearly
violates u.n security council resolution
particularly 2334 of 2016.
the continued violation by israel
authorities
stem from decades of unchecked
accountability
and systemic impunity and this
has we the international community
must act together to end impunity
and to hold israel accountable
the second point is the urgent need for
a comprehensive
and inclusive solution a unilateral
approach
is only unjust but unsustainable in
finding a solution
for the israel-palestinian country a
comprehensive and inclusive
solution is needed
indonesia urges the international
community to focus
all of its efforts towards restarting a
credible
multilateral process that is based on
unresolution
international law and other relevant
internationally agreed parameters
the process which is also first and
foremost
involves direct engagement between two
conflicting parties
israel and palestine i would like to
once again reiterate and echo
president abbas
we would like to also extend our support
for the intra-palestinian unity talk as
an essential
essential steps toward internal
reconciliation
and unified palestine
is the deteriorating humanitarian
situation in the office
the situation in opt continues to worsen
due to coffee 19 pandemic
with more than 60 000 positive cases
and 492 deaths according to you
the huge spike has significant burdens
as well as extra space
an already difficult and challenging
situation
reported more than 6 000 additional
palestinians
in the opt positive for coffee 19
with 90 more as such the role of u.n
agencies such as umrah is more urgent
than ever
the international community should
remain committed to support and ensure
predictable funding and political
backing
where all of us are recommending
ourselves to the spirit and letter
of the un charter we hear this morning
the beautiful poem of miss eleanor
wickstrom youth poet laureate
if the youth of the world asked us what
have we inherited on this issue of
palestine
the answer now would be that the united
nations
inherit despair and sufferings of the
palestinian people
we inherit stories of conflict violence
and violation of human rights by israel
in the palestinian territory
we inherit non-implementation and
non-fulfillment of u.n and security
council resolution
on the issue of
indonesia remains
is
[Music]
international
is
hello
resolution
foreign
[Music]
thank you mr president
is
we encourage regional actors to embrace
the spirit of compromise
and continue to implement
confidence-building matters
we believe that these historic
developments can also give momentum
issues
is
negotiators
to refrain
in the is palestinian territories
including in east jerusalem
regional
[Music]
first
opportunity
from
territories
is
foreign
[Music]
is
manner
foreign
[Music]
in the last week
oh
uh
foreign
is
i thank the distinguished representative
of south africa
and before i thank you all for
participating in this meeting in
particular
minnesota military who stayed with us
throughout the meeting i would like to
express my uh regrets that
that the that ambassador done during his
first
time in the security council could not
be
seen although he was hurt unfortunately
this platform
that we are using for these kind of
meetings despite all
its obvious benefits benefits sometimes
we
experience our problems with it
we will be able to thank
is
you